[Music]
satified is a hefty time sink of a game
with dozens of gameplay mechanics to
master characters to meet books to read
jobs to do and of course shadows to
defeat my first playthrough clocked in
at over 80 hours but in order to get
that sweet sweet platinum I'm gonna need
to hit that new game plus mode and hit
it hard for more persona 5 goodness make
sure you like this video and subscribe
to game Sports YouTube channel for all
the latest including my video review on
John Luke's awesome history a persona
video if you're a fan of the franchise
you should definitely put time aside for
that one so while I'm trophy hunting and
to help you on your playthrough here are
9 things I wish I knew before I started
playing for Sona 5 there are various
ways to boost your stats part-time jobs
hanging with friends and extracurricular
activities for a quick bump head to the
underground walkway in Shibuya station
on Sundays at the juice stand you can
buy a special fruit juice which gives
you points in a different stat every
week a super useful way to get a couple
of extra points without having to
dedicate time to an activity when you
boot up the game you'll be prompted to
connect to the Thieves Guild do it it's
a super super useful tool it offers
loads of helpful snippets if you're
wondering what level you should be to
tackle a specific boss or you just want
to compare your actions against others
then with a press of the touchpad you
can see what other players are up to but
the best reason to connect if you're
stuck in class until stumped on a
question your powers of the Thieves
Guild have your back
it's basically ask the audience from Who
Wants to Be a Millionaire
but please note this doesn't work during
exam season because teaching on exams is
bad ok
[Music]
making friends is important not only in
life but in persona five especially the
closer you are to your allies the more
they'll watch your back in battle make
nice with car wakame and she'll let you
slack off in class meaning you can spend
that time doing something more useful
like reading a book or sleeping spend
time with her Fumi and she'll teach you
some awesome shogi moves that you can
apply in the Metaverse make sure to put
the time in to strengthen these bonds or
if you don't want to put the time in
once you reach rank seven with the
fortune teller you can pay her 5,000 yen
to boost the amount of co-op points you
get each time you hang out with a
confidante meaning you'll be hitting max
rank with min effort you can also do
this with stats and money who fed
fortune tellers were full of crap not
really a tip as much as a reminder of
the tutorial menu that pops up on the
screen at the beginning of the game but
for Sona 5 added autorecover
game-changer no longer have to fight see
trolling through menus to use dia to
heal everyone up just tap square as
you're running around palaces and Bob's
your uncle
everyone's gonna be topped up and ready
to party
[Music]
lockpicks are imported because palaces
are literally full of chests right for
the taking but once the treasure has
been taken from the palace the palace
collapses meaning that that chest you
missed is gone forever spend your
evenings crafting lockpicks which also
ups your proficiency stats and make the
unbreakable lockpick as soon as possible
you need aluminium sheet and liquid
mercury which you can usually find on
the floor in mementos as in real life
reading books is a great way of
improving your characteristics I'm
learning about the city you live in
head to the book store in central street
and you'll be greeted with a selection
of books and magazines to buy and each
of them will improve a different stat
there are also books dedicated to
uncovering new places in the city that
you can travel to when hanging out with
friends once you write about a new place
it'll be added to the map and depending
on who you choose to hang out with you
could improve your confidante rank
quicker and equal when you're wooing
your waifu or husband oh there's a lot
of traveling on the subway in persona 5
and if you've got a book to hand you can
spend that time improving your stats try
and always have something new to read to
make the best use of this time your
third-eye ability is super useful when
solving puzzles as it highlights key
items or footprints in blue tap the left
trigger and you'll see things glow gold
that means there's something worth
taking you'll find some thief after all
once you've liberated that item from the
palace in which you found it you can
then sell it in the real world for mega
yen but no questions asked you should be
grateful
save yourself some bother in battle by
using combos to make easy work of
shadows if an enemy is burning follow up
with a wind attack to fan those flames
your mind or if they're burned shocked
or frozen follow up with a new cleaner
bility if an enemy is asleep they'll be
using that time to replenish SP and use
more abilities on you don't give them
that opportunity give them a whack
across the chops for a technical hit
that deals more damage the many and I
mean many levels of mementos can be
daunting but honestly it's a great place
to grind so don't ignore it if you want
to make things easier for yourself pay
attention to the weather if there's a
heat wave some of the enemies may be
inflicted with a burning status effect
that chips away at their health if
there's a high pollen count
they'll be sleepy and less inclined to
attack you use this time to speed
through levels reach the depths ok bonus
tip if you buy the old TV from the
second-hand store in the back streets
you get a used DVD player thrown in for
free you can rent DVDs from the
Scarlett's store on Central Street and
here's a cheeky hint you can keep those
DVDs for as long as you like you're
threatened with a late fee but for some
reason the game waves it every time you
take an overdue DVD back this never
would have happened at Blockbuster but
it's a nifty little exploit I discovered
nonetheless so there were nine and a
half things I wish I knew before I
started playing persona 5 any other tips
check them in the comments below or come
find me on Twitter I'm at Lucy James
games for more on persona 5 make sure to
like this video and subscribe to
GameSpot
good work everyone
[Music]